welcome to this video playing league why
lick why from Brazil I play caro-kann
yes should I ok I do that again this
this line Oh is not int playing that ok
well just then I'll just develop why not
why not shouldn't be shouldn't be bad 92
ok yeah 93 coming problem yeah but this
isn't this just like a normal line with
the white having lost time mind he goes
now back to he just knew we just lost
time right 97 on night or c5e lc5 there
is 95 in Bishop b5 check yeah I'm like
about two moves up compared to a normal
position i believe
c5 on yeah well this is also move not
bad maybe even intending to take on g3
yeah so he needed to do that and now
maybe Queen a 5d five okay well it's an
interesting way to play if he exchanges
this is a structure that I really like
and TI have b5 trying to establish this
Queen on them on the central square
yeah and now White has a slight problem
he cannot really Castle long anymore
this is completely unsuitable for long
castles and he cannot Castle short as h5
is dropping and this is in fact a
general problem Knight to f6 could
probably just attack the phone and win
it okay interesting on a6 you wants to
play c4 I guess now I can take with the
Queen that's nonsense okay let's play a
6 okay if I go rook c8 there is c4 I am
okay
okay that's interesting
hmm c4 that's a bit bit annoying the
smooth
yeah well that's not entirely ideal a
six was probably a bad move yeah he can
play c4 no he doesn't yeah sometimes you
wonder why you even think so long my bar
moves he obviously had to place he for i
think i can take windey one everything
but still them this must be played okay
um nevertheless he he didn't didn't do
it maybe a six now s week I don't want
to play night PA this looks totally sick
my problem yeah top books yet to
counter-attack but after okay success
always d6 hang that I overlooked okay
yeah that's not ideal but okay what else
keep a six
yeah yeah maybe even take with the rock
yes'm I didn't I didn't take that so
serious at first but it's not bad okay i
want my night as a defense of peace
night on f5 maybe so Queen g4 ibook g4
there's nine f5 down one minute forty
yeah that's great
yeah not much choice here need to grab
ya I'm not sure about the position ready
it's white better maybe maybe and I'm
not well I'm not bad in terms of
centralizing so or pieces some fulfill
some roller now it shouldn't be totally
terrible it's taking some time that's
good
brought to blunder that not bad better
not okay I don't really know tough v5 is
not a move that a lie that I'd really
like to play wit when she found
counterplay here on the sea far I saw
that this is hanging fruit loop takes
and sought this one to get to to see two
and a tough tough position it shouldn't
be bad really I hope check time warning
check
check Luke h8 checkmate either say I'm a
day I went into a self-made but he
didn't didn't he didn't play it wow just
wow 25 then to d5 him immediately it
wasn't possible you know that that will
be tricky look at seven probably a
bishop is seven probably
care or that one like I have five eyes
got this check as well he's got this
check now yeah nothing nothing that I
can do I must do that maybe it's still
somewhat playable I don't know yeah but
this is Jack still far better than what
I had before
check yes unfortunately losing yeah okay
black yeah yeah okay why I mean
considering he could have mated mean one
move heck it is probably deserved
results I mean yeah right here I'm okay
really not jack it wasn't easy to play I
mean this is cool who catch admit simply
simply overlooked it so I came yeah now
this is it's it's so good for white ham
96 and wide resides yeah I wasn't really
technically fresh in the skin maybe this
is just the current coincidence it's not
really related to the position that I is
this kind of mostly win games and here
I'm just lost I know it's a draw okay
yeah we cannot expect much quality with
this little time at the end yeah but
what what did what what would I mean
this is just
getting like a couple extra move so I
should be totally fine here i guess i
need to improve right here yeah hits he
of course he for him but he didn't do
that here just a matter of precision so
what is the move to give me the edge one
this this is isn't Adam this is not the
rule Bishop d7 it seems is better okay I
must play that one kicking him back and
only is then before I wanted to play
with before somebody to keep the seaport
at home and then get the night to this
brilliant square and once I arrived
there i'm just an excellent shape and
this is in fact good for white or black
this thing is that this is just not not
doing anything I'm covering here and in
this position it's not possible and now
I need to play this this wrong move I
mean it still still a position but not
not ideal yeah tough okay thanks for
watching